hey everyone its micromotor closed and I
want to talk to you today about the
upcoming webinar I have on Thursday June
7th where I'll be talking about the new
order flows 2.0 trading in sync with the
market and I'll be the first speaker of
6 with investor inspiration this
Thursday so you can register by going to
the link below or you can go into the
description I have a direct link to
invest your inspiration either one will
take you to the same place and what I'll
be talking about is how to let the
market tell you when to buy and sell how
to trade in the present based on what's
happening now as opposed to trading
based on what happened you know 20 30
bars ago when you're using other types
of indicators and I'll talk about new
developments in order flow analysis that
you can apply to your trading tomorrow
as soon as you get up and running with
order flow software what to look for
what you know what not to concentrate on
and more importantly what to concentrate
on and I will show you how to easily see
high percentage order flow trade setups
now again you know you just register you
go to order closed com / registered HTML
it's free you get access to the replay
once it's available and if you don't
learn from me hopefully you can learn
something from some of the other 5
speakers on that day so thanks and I
hope to see you there on Thursday bye
bye